Then you go over COVID supplementation recommendations that folks should have on hand.
So I'm not exactly sure if you're asking.
So things to prevent COVID or other possible pathogens or viruses or bacteria that could
be coming down the road, I would answer that this way.
So we have a product called ClearCV that was created specifically for this.
We created it during COVID and it has the things, you know, zinc, vitamin C, vitamin
A, etc., that are just in a great blend to help prevent viral issues if you're afraid
of getting a virus.
So that was why we created it during COVID when people were afraid of going to the store
and getting, you know, infected with a virus.
So ClearCV is the name of it and it stands for, what is it for cold virus or something like
that or COVID?
I don't know.
Well, we couldn't say COVID on the label, so we just called it ClearCV.
Now it isn't specific to any one virus and it's not even specific to viruses, it would
be more antipathogen to prevent infections.
Now what would happen if I got sick if I, you know, I wanted some recommendations to have
on hand for my family if we got ill, well, that would depend on what it is.
So if it's viral or if it's bacterial, that would be a little bit different.
But we have some different immune supplements that would be, you know, for either one, aloevia
immune would be a great supplement, that's a polysaccharide in a specific form that has been
shown with research to really boost T cells and natural killer cells, so it's great for
cancer.
But it's also great for bacteria and viruses too.
There's different herbs that would be really good for any certain bacteria and cancers, garlic,
oregano, acadacea that are really good for different conditions.
Now that being said, the caveat to that is, is if you have a known autoimmune disease,
then you have to be careful not to take immune stimulants on a regular basis as a preventative
because you'd be up-regulated in your immune system, and if you haven't had antibodies
to neural tissue, let's say brain tissue, then you could be, you know, causing more destruction
on a daily basis of that neural tissue that you have antibodies against because would
you up-regulate your immune system, you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against
first, which is your own tissue if you have an autoimmune disease.
Now if you have cancer, you've got to kind of throw that out and we've got to up-regulate
our immune system because we've got to kill the cancer.
But you have to weigh that out, let's say you don't have cancer, your family doesn't have
cancer, but my wife has, you know, Hashimoto's thyroid, should she be taking clear CV on
a daily basis, I would say no, probably not, but if you feel like you're exposed to something,
you feel like you're coming down to something in an acute situation, you can certainly take
immune stimulants.